so there we all were looking forward to
the arrival of baby Sussex in boom Megan
and Harry make the announcements that
there will be no announcement on the
birth of their child because they want
to celebrate quotes privately as a
family okay someone needs to explain to
me our statement announcing the baby's
name weight and gender would invade
their privacy or deny them precious
family time this is an unprecedented
slap in the face for those legions of
decent ordinary people who love the
royal family and who see the royal birth
as a Jewish national celebration
celebration they've now been shut out of
no one's expecting Megan to parade her
baby minutes after giving birth and of
course they're entitled to private time
with baby Sussex but how hard would it
be to spend two measly minutes outside
the hospital waving and smiling at
people who only want to wish them well
us Brits gives so much to the royal
family we also pay for the privilege of
having them isn't it time the Royals
gave something back and I love you in
many ways you talk about like a joyous
national celebration when a royal baby a
lot of people it is not for that many
people there are some people who gather
outside their respective husband and I
wish them nothing but well but I have to
say this I have to say this and don't
hos wrong I think you're going back to
another age I really do when they were
expected to do this and I don't think
it's I don't think anybody could tell a
couple how they should or should not
celebrate the birth of their child it is
an intensely personal I take the point
that we put I don't know that we
actually pay that much when I was at
work were he the next in line I could
start to come to your way of thinking
he's not the next in line in fact this
child against seven so the baby will be
yes back in perhaps the fifties and
sixties you might put on yes if this job
is going to be king or queen around hon
let the couple celebrate the way they
see fit and Percy I wish them nothing to
happiness but it's not a national
holiday this this is a couple
we talked about previously about wanting
privacy there's a couple of what their
wedding invited 2,000 ordinary people to
their wedding because they wanted to
involve people the public at large and
yet they're shutting those people I
don't think I'm going back to a but
Karen let me finish please I'll for you
I'm not going back to a bygone age I'm
talking about people you say we don't
pay we've just paid three million quid
for the renovation of Frogmore house
that's one thing we've paid and we pay
we paid thirty two million quid for
their wedding there's another thing but
there can be as private as they'd like
but don't be a royal don't take the
money the the number of points here
about the royal family and you know they
are a huge asset to this country in many
ways and and then in terms of the whole
world they are the most prominent royal
family in the world
they bring billions into this country so
whatever we do to pay for the royal
family they pay back many many times
over then the point that Nick made about
tradition let's have a look at the
pictures of how this has been done in
the past you know there's an expectation
when William and Kate and Prince George
was was born and the pictures outside
the hospital the Lindo wing this is what
we're used to this has been going back
now to Princess Anne and her children a
Prince Charles and Princess Diana it's a
tradition no we are breaking with
tradition over here Megan is is breaking
the mold she is different
she's a highly highly intelligent highly
articulate individual who's bringing a
difference to those around me how hard
would it have been how difficult would
it be to give so many people so much
done
two minutes outside a hospital can I
raise a possible reason with you what do
you want do you just want the baby I
could know I've tried to work out what
what you're so upset about we want to
know when the baby is born what the sex
of the baby is and maybe the birth way
to the baby and you want Megan to appear
with the baby at some point after the
baby's birth does it occur to you that
Megan may need a caesarean how well it
does how on earth kind of a suit does
not major apparently so what you think
I'm saying
holding a bundle of joy arguments about
it that is a possibility she's a woman
of 37 or do you think if she was having
bad Aryan she might say why should she
she may have planned an electic ovarian
which would explain why she's not going
to do a photo call after the birth also
why the hell heck should she present her
baby to the world it's their baby cuz
she has married into a family that it
has protocols and traditions if you
don't want to be part of that fine don't
live a private life she they don't have
it it's her private medical business if
she is having a planned elective
cesarean why should she tell me you're
saying this like it's fact cow if that
was the case of course not well first of
all and just to say I work with a lot of
charities that the Sussex r66 support so
I don't want to get too involved in this
conversation but number one if you look
at the way the Dutchess of Sussex has
been treated by the press recently I'm
not surprised she doesn't want to come
and parade her baby in terms of how is
she doing it out of spite and secondly
you can't have it both ways Carol
because you're often talking about
Hollywood women and the pressures on
them to look good and so on and now
you're then saying something else and I
want to bring in a quote from Keira
Knightley this is what she said in
Scarlett curtis's book about feminism
and she said Kate was out of hospital
seven hours later with her face made up
and high heels on the face the world
wants to see look beautiful look stylish
don't show your battleground Kate seven
hours after your fight with life and
death seven hours after your body breaks
open bloody screaming life comes out
don't show don't tell you set an
unrealistic image for women to see and
actually we have to get to a place where
we allow women to choose for them to the
most important point it is their choice
I mean the birth of your first child to
me it is one of the most special moments
of my life and I see what they're not
saying they're never going to be proper
choosing when they
going into the hospital or going into
their home we're talking about a couple
of minutes for that for the legions of
people who support and don't say it's a
handful of people who turn up events it
isn't it's people who travel just do it
in their own way this is a very small
amount of their time honestly think you
and Fleet Street as fort if it still
existed you're out of the mood with the
nation is what let me show you some of
the headlines of recent Megan Markel
nicknamed me gain by disgruntled
Kensington Palace staff from the metro
megan Markel snubs queen's doctors for
our own birth team as mum flies in from
LA Daily Mirror a royally expensive
party Megan Marvel's baby shower cost
are staggering
four hundred and thirty thousand dollars
Daily Mail megan Markel in danger of
neglecting Prince Harry after royal baby
birth claims expert Daily Express that's
not the mood I'm telling you that's not
how people feel towards this cup no and
then and I wouldn't want to be standing
in front of those people after they've
written that about me so sorry she's
okay I just says now you said that you
said she's doing it because the press
have been better I'm not saying let me
finish because she's a Hollywood star
and it matters how she looks they seem
like pretty trivial reasons to me [ __ ]
when you're talking about you're talking
about people the Queen subject who
actually just want to have a little
share in this you're just broken away
their households they've started their
own independent household they want to
do things their own way put pictures of
the baby on their Instagram account
what's the difference tell me what the
difference is between hospital and
posting beautifully edited pictures on
their Instagram account what's the
difference because it's in it's a
personal decision if that's what they
want to do no one can tell him another
couple how to present their challenge of
the work you could just about argue if
he was going to be all she was gonna be
King awkward I just about get it but
otherwise it's there to say chily the
petition not matter anymore protocols
don't matter traditions are there to be
broken
what are they this
it's reach back the Cajuns younger days
in the old days the poor mark Queen had
to give birth with Cortez in the room to
prove she giving birth you know we are
have moved on Carole and so must we